[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen schönen guten abend bei scobel
meine damen und herren heute zum thema
zeit der film den sie gerade sehen
konnten zeigte wie zeit sich dehnen kann
sie haben das sicher auch schon erlebt
langeweile wird geradezu körperlich
erfahren eine erfahrung die im
extremfall krank machen kann
in der sendung werden sie noch sehen
warum das so ist und warum die erfahrung
von zeit so stark an körperwahrnehmung
und prozesse in unserem gehirn gebunden
ist
langeweile aber auch das gegenteil
nämlich die rasante beschleunigung die
wir in vielen alltags prozessen erleben
zeigen wie nahe uns die zunächst
scheinbar so abstrakte größe zeit kommt
so nah dass wir eins mit ihr werden und
die wahrnehmung von zeit unser ganzes
sein geist und körper bestimmt und
überlagert vor zwei tagen erschien die
untersuchung einer amerikanischen
anthropologin namens paul wißler die
zeigen konnte dass die erfindung des
feuers unter anderem dazu führte uns im
unterschied zu anderen affenarten rund
vier stunden zeit pro tag mehr zu gehen
diese zeit am feuer war eine wesentliche
ursache für intensivere kommunikation
und die entstehung zb von erzählungen
die wiederum dazu dienten eine virtuelle
gemeinschaft mit fern menschen aber auch
mit dingen oder mit den toten entstehen
zu lassen
ihr fazit die kulturelle technische
innovation der erfindung oder man könnte
auch sagen findung und zähmung des
feuers führte zu einer veränderung
unseres zeit haushaltes und damit zur
entstehung von kommunikation literatur
und neuen gemeinschafts formen die uns
einen entscheidenden evolutionären
vorteil gegenüber anderen affenarten
sichert zeit ist kultur und bestimmt
unser leben
allerdings kamen nach der erfindung des
feuers natürlich noch viele technische
und kulturelle entwicklungen die auf die
zeit bezogen sind und unser leben
grundlegend verändert haben
der wunsch die zeit zu erfassen ist so
alt wie die menschheit sind sonne mond
und sterne waren für unsere vorfahren in
früheren kulturen die wegweiser
im harz nutzten menschen vor über 3000
jahren eine kupfer scheibe die
himmelsscheibe von nebra um nach der
bewegung der gestirne den besten
zeitpunkt für aussaat und ernte zu
bestimmen
die kelten setzten ein heiligtum aus
steinen unter den himmel
stonehenge hier beobachteten sie die
bewegungen der gestirne die schatten
längen und den winkel der sonne
die himmelsboten bestimmten das
alltagsleben verabredung haben
eigentlich immer nur geklappt über
gestirne vollmond neumond soviel tage
vorher so viel tage nachher und dem
sonnenstand also in rom war es so dass
ein sklave auf dem forum stand und
beobachtete an welchen säulen die sonne
gerade vorbei ging und das ausgerufen
hat durch akustische zeichen noch keine
glocken gießen später musste man anfängt
und er war pünktlich schluss bei
sonnenuntergang mit der sonnenuhr hatte
man es einfacher der römische dichter
plautus klagte vor 2000 jahren das rom
voll sei von den sonnenuhren erbaut um
zitat seine tage zu zerfetzen brauchte
man ein exaktes zeitmaß behalf man sich
damals mit der wasseruhr sollte jemand
vor gericht länger reden dürfen riefen
die zuschauer mehr wasser
im alltag der meisten menschen
existierte keine uhr ihr leben war
bestimmt durch die tägliche zeit der
tage monate und jahreszeiten und dem
ritual wiederkehrender feste ein jahr
glich dem anderen das leben in den
frühen kulturen doch im ganzen
mittelalter ist ja in einem ganz
ungewöhnlichen grad bestimmt durch die
religiösen vorstellungen jeden monat ein
bis zwei götter feste zu denen die
menschen zusammengekommen sind und die
ja nicht nur politisch religiöse
funktion hatten sondern auch soziale
politische funktionen um die menschen
zusammenzuführen
die menschen lebten von tag zu tag
längere zeitspannen waren für sie nicht
von bedeutung des und 17 jahrhundert
kannten die wenigsten ihr geburtsdatum
im mittelalter wurde das klosterleben
von derzeit für andacht und gebet
bestimmt gottes zeit sollte nicht vertan
werden schon bald schmückte eine neue
zeitmaschine die räder uhr kirchtürme
und rathäuser und versuchte dem alltag
zu orten
bedeutet wurde bei jeder denkbaren
gelegenheiten wollen die geschäfte
aufmachen wenn die geschäfte zu machen
waren die tür die stadttore schließen
wann die tore geöffnet werden wann ein
brandfall eintritt wenn eine versammlung
stattfindet immer wurde geläutet in
einer mittelalterlichen stadt
es gab ja auch viele viele kirchen wo es
ständig gebündelt haben
aber die leute wussten was das bedeutet
die wirtschaftliche und politische
bedeutung der städte nahm zu hier legten
die kaufleute die händler erkannten den
wert der zeit zeit wurde zu geld wenn
sie ein betrieb hat mit hunderten von
mitarbeitern wir müssen die pünktlich
anfangen
der schneider selber kann bestimmen weil
er anfängt oder nicht aber bei einem
großbetrieb nicht bewusst dass geregelt
sein und das geht dann eben im 15
jahrhundert central los wegen des immer
stärker werdenden produktions drucks
durch die industrialisierung wurde das
alltagsleben zu einem wettlauf gegen die
zeit die stechuhren in den fabriken
tickten maschinen gaben das arbeitstempo
vor
jetzt musste der mensch selbst wie ein
rädchen im uhrwerk funktionieren durch
die dampfmaschine wurden die
produktionsprozesse weiter beschleunigt
die eisenbahn veränderte durch ihre
geschwindigkeit das zeitempfinden der
menschen und führte zu einer revolution
in der zeitrechnung
[Musik]
gemeint ist die vereinheitlichung der
urzeit jede stadt in deutschland hat
ihren eigenen mittag gehabt ihre eigene
uhr muss die uhr umstellen auf jedem
bahnhof aber nur einen bauplan wachen
grunde braucht man überall die gleiche
zeit
1893 erließ daher kaiser wilhelm der
zweite ein gesetz zur einführung einer
einheitlichen zeitbestimmung fast
gleichzeitig wurde die ganze welt in
zeitzonen eingeteilt
heute leben wir im zeitalter der
gleichzeitigkeit durch die rasante
datenübertragung haben wir jederzeit
zugriff auch auf weit entfernte
ereignisse die gleichzeitigkeit schafft
neue anforderungen
das zeitalter der globalen vernetzung
zwingt menschen ständig erreichbar und
aktiv zu sein dabei heute haben wir eine
extrem kurze arbeitszeit das heißt wenn
wir das auf die lebenszeit um rechnet
mit dem arbeitsbeginn mit dem ruhestand
mit den feiertagen mit den ferien
ansprüchen und so weiter arbeiten wir
heute ungefähr ein drittel zu lange beim
19 jahrhundert setzt sich der arbeits
und leistungsdruck der arbeitswelt in
der freizeit fort
warum wird die verfügbare zeit
freiwillig mit immer mehr terminen
verplant zeit gibt es in allen kulturen
und epochen sinn und bedeutung
erschließen sich aber erst in dem
jeweiligen kulturellen und zeitlichen
kontext
ja viele fragen und die kläre ich jetzt
mit meinem heutigen gästen die gäste der
sendung sind marc widmann
er studierte psychologie und philosophie
forscht an der universität san diego im
bereich psychiatrie entwickelte eine
neue theorie derzeit wahrnehmung des
professor am institut für grenzgebiete
der psychologie und psychohygiene in
freiburg dann muss sich dirk becker er
studierte soziologie ist ein
ausgewiesener fachmann für systemtheorie
und lehrt und forscht professor für
kulturtheorie und analyse an der
zeppelin universität in friedrichshafen
und mein dritter gast normandie rocker
ist philosoph mathematiker und
promovierter physiker mit einer
doktorarbeit über neurophysiologische
aspekte derzeit wahrnehmung erforscht an
der eth zürich so und erwähnen will ich
noch dass meine gäste zu ihrem
jeweiligen gebiet eine reihe von büchern
geschrieben haben die ich jetzt hier
unerwähnt lassen sie finden sie aber und
nähere informationen dazu auf unserer
homepage www 3sat.de scobel
wir haben uns gerade den film über
zeitmessung und die zeit wahrnehmung
angesehen ich würde sie gerne zum anfang
nur ganz kurz fragen was war für sie
jeweils das bedeutendste ereignis in der
kulturgeschichte der zeitmessung bzw der
erforschung der zeit
freiwillige vor
ich glaube die armbanduhr
denn was die gemacht hat ist also nicht
nur dass sie uns jetzt synchronisiert
mit einer menschen sondern dass sie
eigentlich unser ganzes privatleben in
zeiteinheiten unterteilt wir plötzlich
anfangen alles mögliche zu messen
insignia angemessen ja meine privaten
körperlichen bedürfnisse die dauer alles
kann ich plötzlich in sekunden genau
messen und das alles was privat waren
völlig zeitlos eigentlich wird plötzlich
mit zeit besetzt ich war noch erste
klasse schultüte uhr plötzlich habe ich
angefangen zu messen fünf sekunden 10
sekunden was mit lang dauert etwas hand
tragen sie nur ich trage auch keine
interessanten also eine wichtige
voraussetzung vielleicht noch um für die
ganze zeitmessung würde sagen die anfang
der geschichtsschreibung also das finde
ich auch noch interessant punkte wenn
man in der antike angefangen hat zu
sagen wir haben wirklich eine lineare
zeit ordnung in der wir alles verordnen
müssen denn das war ja bis zum 5
jahrhundert vor christus und auch nicht
der fall da hatte das irgendwie
tradition es war und es war wichtig dass
man vielleicht das was in der odyssee
und in der ilias mit dem trojanischen
krieg passiert ist dass man das weiß
aber nicht wann das genau war ob das
irgendwie 50 oder 100 jahre her war
vollkommen egal dass das zu einer
bestimmten zeiten bewusstsein entstanden
dass wir überhaupt uns verorten
gegenüber diesen anderen sachen und das
so als voraussetzung dafür dass wir dann
überhaupt die gäste zum laufen gekriegt
haben mich beeindrucken künstlerische
interventionen die uns auf gewohnheiten
aufmerksam machen die uns anderenfalls
nicht bewusst würden der erste künstler
der die armbanduhr abgenommen hat die
würde ich gerne kennen aber ich denke
man vor allem an dieses großartige
orgelprojekt orgelprojekt von von john
cage das aktuell im dom von halberstadt
639 jahre lang aufgeführt wird und dass
er publik dass er geschrieben hat mit 18
jahren mit der anweisung as slow as
possible so dass man in diesen dom
hinein geht ich war selbst noch nicht da
es mir berichten lassen und kaum erahnt
im hintergrund dass dort ein ton klingt
und nur noch die eine frage gestellt
wird dieser ton sich irgendwann in einen
anderen ton verändern und wie ist das
verhältnis dieses zweiter zum ersten ton
wenn dann mittlerweile schon drei monate
vier monate zum teil nach längerer zeit
verstrichen sind überhaupt zu begreifen
ja das wirft mich zurück auf die frage
wie lange bin ich in der lage und bin
ich bereit etwas zu erwarten dass sich
ändert im verhältnis zu dem was ich
gerade eben erlebe ja vielen dank es ist
gespräch und unser erster film hat ihnen
ja kleinen einblick gegeben in die
kulturgeschichte der zeit und der
zeitmessung
es liegt nahe sich daher jetzt zunächst
mal mit dem naturwissenschaftlichen
begriff der zeit zu befassen und
naturwissenschaftlich verstand man über
jahrhunderte hinweg bis vor wenigen
jahren im grunde immer nur eins nämlich
das nachdenken über den physikalischen
mit hilfe mathematischer formeln
erfassten zeitbegriff die mathematik die
dazu nötig ist ist nicht gerade die
einfachste und die physikalischen
vorstellung und schlussfolgerungen die
sich aus der mathematischen darstellung
etwa in der relativitätstheorie ergeben
sind oft noch schwerer nachvollziehbar
weil unser alltag so anders zu sein
scheint im grunde genommen ist es immer
noch wie im mittelalter neben dem
physikalische mathematische nachdenken
muss man sich dem thema auch
philosophisch nähern
sehen sie jetzt unsere kurze und ich
glaube verständliche physik geschichte
der gesamten zeit in der klassischen
mechanik ist die zeit etwas
unveränderliches die absolute ware zeit
schrieb newton verfliest an sich und
vermögen ihrer natur gleichförmig und
ohne beziehung zu irgendeinem äußeren
gehirn stand es gibt keine
wechselwirkungen zwischen raum und zeit
der raum ist unendlich die zeit ist
unendlich beide sind unabhängig von
irgendwelchen bezugssystem
dies ist die zeit wie wir sie im alltag
handhaben mit der relativitätstheorie
albert einsteins verliert die zeit ihren
absolutheitsanspruch es gibt keine
universelle gleichzeitigkeit mehr das
vorher und nachher existiert nur in
bezug auf einzelne systeme oder einzelne
beobachter die zeit bildet zusammen mit
dem raum die vier dimensionale raumzeit
blicken schneller oder langsamer
vergehen
letztlich ist die zeit abhängig von der
bewegung also von der geschwindigkeit je
schneller wir uns bewegen umso langsamer
tickt eine uhr das heißt wenn sie bus
fahren zum beispiel an tickt eine uhr
langsamer als an der haltestelle man
muss dann immer relativ
geschwindigkeiten ins spiel bringen also
ohne miteinander vergleichen
die effekte der zeit dehnung sind winzig
aber mit atomuhren messbar
neben der geschwindigkeit wird die zeit
auch von der gravitation der schwerkraft
beeinflusst
wenn sie massen haben dann tickt da auch
nur anders die zeit wird gedehnt in der
nähe der master tickt eine uhr langsamer
wenn sie weiter weg sind tickt die uhr
schneller
das sind die effekte die man auch dann
messen konnte mit turm experimenten mit
flugzeugen und sonnten sowie die
relativitätstheorie den makrokosmos das
universum beschreibt so beschreibt die
quantenphysik den mikrokosmos die
zusammensetzung der materie
statt des raum zeit kontinuum es gibt es
hier wieder eine trennung von raum und
zeit wie in der klassischen physik bei
newton
die zeit ist dann entwicklungs parameter
losgelöst vom raum sind ja verschiedene
größten in der quantenphysik indiskrete
einheiten in portionen sozusagen
verpackt die energie gehört da dazu die
energiepaketes energie quandt auch die
strahlung gehört dazu strahlungsenergie
ist gepackt in portionen sozusagen aber
die zeit selbst es eben nicht auf die
art und weise kritisiert
es gibt allerdings neue theorien die
noch nicht sich bewährt haben die man
also erst experimentell testen muss die
sowas annehmen für die zeit bedeutet das
dass sie in wirklich winzige portionen
gepackt wäre von 10 - 44 sekunden also
das sind so kurze zeiträume die sind
nicht messbar
hier sind wir also in einem bereich der
spekulation in denen die experimentelle
physik noch nicht vordringen kann
einfacher haben es die physiker mit dem
phänomen des zeit heilt die zeit hat
eine eindeutige und unumkehrbare
richtung
am einfachsten ist dieser zeit fall zu
beobachten wenn ein gegenstand wie etwa
ein glas in viele teile zerspringt
dieser vorgang ist wie wir wissen
unumkehrbar
in der thermodynamik wird diese richtung
derzeit als zunahme der entropie und
damit der unordnung in einem
abgeschlossenen system definiert es gibt
stets eine zunahme von unordnung und
eine abnahme von ordnung das gilt auf
der erde wie im kosmos wenn wir als
astronom rausschauen in den kosten
erstellt man eben fest dass man
irgendwann in eine zeit zurück schaut wo
es also noch gar keine sterne und
galaxien gab
das heißt man kann auch hier einen zeit
parameter finden an kosmologischen zeit
wo man feststellt die weiter ich
zurückgehe
umso früher sind die phasen und so
anders ist das universum auch
strukturiert es gab noch keine sterne es
gab noch keine galaxien geht man noch
weiter zurück zum prognostizierten
urknall dann kommt man in anderen
bereich wo es keine physikalischen
prozesse mehr gibt dann gibt es aber
auch keine zeitmessung mehr keine uhren
und damit auch keine zeit
das wäre sozusagen denkbar dass wir ganz
am anfang eine zeit haben ohne zeit ein
universum ohne zeit irgendwann startet
die zeit weil das universum strukturen
bildet dann dehnt sich das universum aus
kühlt dann irgendwann ab das ist das
aktuelle favorisierte modell des
universum expandiert beschleunigt das
wird immer kühler immer dunkler werden
und kommt dann so auf die art und weise
auch wieder diesen zustand zurück wenn
es am anfang hatte nämlich an quanten
universum was also aus
vakuum besteht wo wir wieder keine uhren
mehr haben das heißt auch am ende würde
das bedeuten könnte man spekulieren dass
es keine zeit mehr gibt noch leben wir
in einem universum in dem es zeit gibt
die moderne physik lehrt uns jedoch dass
diese zeit relativ ist
andreas müller sagt je nachdem auf
welcher räumlich und scala wir uns
bewegen müssen wir unserer betrachtung
der welt ein anderes konzept der zeit
zugrunde legen sie rocker das ist schon
ein bisschen verwirrend also für mich
zumindest also am anfang und am ende der
welt was auch immer das ist gab es keine
zeit weder raum weder raum noch zeit
wenn man sich mit quantenphysik
unterhält dann sagen die na ja auf der
ebene gibt es auch keine zeit weil kürzt
sich immer raus als biologische
lebewesen dann haben wir ständig mit
zeit zu tun es gibt den zeit teil also
die gerichte teilt eine völlig andere
erfahrung als die die offensichtlich im
makro und im mikrokosmos gilt wieso ist
das so also vielleicht zuerst zu dieser
zeit ohne zeit also ganz am anfang kann
es am ende ja das hat wurde auch im
interview gesagt das sind spekulative
konzept also ich glaube wenn wir uns
erst mal daran halten was sind die
etablierten theorien die auch wirklich
hervorragend bestätigt sind dann haben
wir da eben die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie für die gravitation
das kann ja auch und auf der anderen
seite die quantenphysik für die anderen
wechselwirkung für elektro dynamik und
so und es ist klar dass die beiden
theorien bestimmt phänomen bereich
beschreiben und dass wir da aber eine
grenze kommen können die theorien sind
sogar so schön dass wir uns quasi selber
sagen wann sie nicht mehr gültig sind
genau und das ist das was sie an diesem
beitrag kam diese 10 44 sekunden also
ein milliardstel von einem trojaner auch
nicht mehr messen können wir im moment
nicht sagen haben dazu das experiment zu
messen und an der stelle wissen wir
einfach nicht was los ist da kennen wir
die physik nicht
das heißt an der stelle wissen natürlich
auch nicht was von zeit konzept gilt
aber daraus zu extrapolieren dann gibt
es keine zeit das finde ich sozusagen
eine ziemlich steile man müsste sehr
korrekter sagen wenn ich innerhalb der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie denke
und mit die bedingungen am anfang so
weit wir die rekonstruieren können
vorstelle dann folgt daraus es gibt
keine zeit
ja genau hängt dann eben von der
kombination auf die und es dann halt wie
gesagt spekulativ weil ich glaube ein
eine sache die ja nachvollziehbar ist
ist dass man sagt wir haben auf der
einen seite so was wie die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie auf der anderen
seite haben blieb die quantenfeldtheorie
heute und das erstaunlich ist man immer
da geht es ja eine physikalische
realität egal ob ich jetzt über galaxien
oder über atom ich das eigentlich müsste
es dann doch dasselbe kommt es derzeit
konzept geben und dann versucht man das
zu verbinden und das ist halt nicht so
nicht so trivial und wie es auch im film
kam
es sind tatsächlich unterschiedliche
konzepte und die bleiben auch
verschieden und im moment haben wir
keine theorie die beides verbinden genau
genau dass das in der 1
in dem einen fall haben wir eben diese
dynamische zeit in der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie über das wo die zeit
selber eine dynamische größe innerhalb
der theorie ist das ist irgendwie was
sehr ungewohntes und dem anderen fall
bei auch bei der quantenfeldtheorie ist
es letztlich immer noch so wie bei
newton als der zweite sohn parameter der
läuft da der läuft damit genau und jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen ja aber was ist
denn das 5 also jetzt sich die physiker
noch
nicht mal ein ich bei so einem
grundlegenden konzept wie derzeit ist ja
dass sie sich bei vielmehr nicht einig
sind
genau aber was auf der anderen seite
eben sagen kann es gibt halt keine
naturwissenschaftlichen theorien die so
wahnsinnig gut präzise belegt sind wie
diese beiden theorien und und das hat ja
sozusagen dass es ihre
existenzberechtigung und ein teil der
erfolgsgeschichte dafür siegt dann
natürlich in dem moment auch daran dass
man sich dann nicht immer gleich um die
fragen kann man nur was ist zeit nun
eigentlich sondern dass diese die sachen
halt diese zeit konzepte zu so oft diese
typisch philosophische frage was ist
eine zeit muss man eigentlich antworten
pass auf wenn du die frage beantworten
willst müssen wir erst mal klar machen
in welchen theoretischen kontext willst
du die frage beantworten so und dann
kann man sich entscheiden also
relativistische quantenmechanisch
alltagstauglich genau ja das war ja das
beispiel aus der aus dem film die die
thermodynamik der anwalt in den
zeitfehler so fragen sich woher kommt
die gerichteter zeit dann sprechen wir
plötzlich oder den beitrag kommt dann
halt ja das ist alles wunderbar das
kennen wir aus der thermodynamik da
stimmt natürlich ist aber auch wieder
ein bereich keiner weiß wie eine
allgemeine relativistische thermodynamik
aussieht als auch die sachen kriegen wir
nicht kriegen wir nicht zusammen aber
wir haben überall extrem gut
funktionierende zeit konzepte und er
stelle aber eben kein einheitliches
kommentar
das sind für einen psychologen sei es
zeit ist kann man ganz unmittelbar
spüren und wenn ich jemand in einen raum
sperre für eine stunde dann wird derzeit
massiv spüren und für den gibt es
überhaupt keine frage ob es zeit ist er
wie zeit ist und da ist es zeit auch
wieder was ganz körperliches auf mich
bezogen ist also zeit für psychologen
eigentlich auf der phänomenalen eben
etwas ganz leicht ist wie es genau
funktioniert machen wir machen wir im
nächsten schritt wir sind haben ja
gesagt wir beschäftigen uns erstmal mit
er mit der physik für den soziologen
gegen das umgekehrte solo ist
überglücklich dass es so viele zeit
konzepte gibt weil man das gefühl hat
auch damit nur damit kommen wir an
beispielsweise sehr unterschiedliche
kulturelle seinerzeit wahrnehmungen
heran nur damit kommen wir an die an die
möglichkeit zeitdruck zeit dehnung zeit
streckung und verschiedenste dinge auch
im sozialen zugriff auf zeit zu
begreifen heran
wenn man sich vorstellen müsste das die
physiker ein einziges zeit konzept haben
würde man in der einheit einer welt
landen bitte die dass die soziologe
erschrecken würde es wird auch die
physik einstecken fertig und die physik
fertig es gibt ja auch ein zeitphänomen
eben das gefühl von jetzt zeitig kite
von dass die physik nicht haben jetzt
ein universums jetzt gibt es ja in der
physik nicht aber das haben wir als
menschen ganz unmittelbar und soll jetzt
gefühl ja genau also das hängt damit
zusammen neben der physik an unseren
also welches zeit konzept jetzt auch
immer nehmen aber haben quasi ein
parameter irgendwas mit irgendetwas mit
früher später relation zu tun hat also
spricht manchmal von lage zeit und eben
nicht dieses jetzt erleben und
vergangenheit und zukunft das spielt
heute in der physik in den theorien
keine rolle weil das jetzt ich meine
dass das elektron dass da irgend
übergang im atommacht das braucht kein
jetzt also jetzt diese rede war so wird
ja wichtig wenn wir von von handlungen
von zwei reden aber solange wir in der
physik üblichkeit von wirk ursachen
reden dann ist einfach früher später es
ist die letzte korrelation die noch
nicht mal physisch sein muss sondern in
den mathematischen modell besteht genau
dass da muss sozusagen eine
unterscheidung die wir dann fuhr er
hinterher nennen können aber da muss
einfach nur eine unterscheidung bestehen
und das reicht aus genetisch genau genau
das ja das ist letztlich der punkt als
andere sozusagen in dem sinne beiwerk
wenn wir da jetzt noch stärkere alltags
konzepte von jappy kausalität dann genau
das was ich habe versucht jedenfalls das
buch von von lee smolin im universum
derzeit einen neuen buch von ihm zu
lesen die jetzt besprochen auf unserer
internetseite
er sagt leute hört doch mal auf damit
das zu machen was er lange zeit gemacht
habt als physiker nämlich eigentlich
immer vom raum her zu denken und die
zeit dann sozusagen als ein phänomen des
raums zu betrachten
sondern nehmt doch mal unsere
psychologische erfahrung ernst er sagt
das ein bisschen anders aber im prinzip
macht er das fand von derzeit aus
anzudenken
und dann macht er den vorschlag und sagt
wer sagt denn dass die gesetze die ihr
in der physik immer entwickelt zeitlos
sein müssen
es kann doch auch sein das ist so eine
art von evolution der physikalischen
gesetze gibt und das heißt dass nicht
alle gesetze über alle zeiten hinweg
gültig sind können sie was sagen zudem
zu der idee ich fand das faszinierend
also mit einem evolutionsbedingt man die
zahlen ranzugehen also an die gesetze
die uns zeit definieren run zu hören ja
ich meine eine möglichkeit gibt es
natürlich die haben wir auch schon
länger dass man sagen kann
naturkonstanten die in den theorien
vorkommen die unterliegen selber einer
zeitlichen entwicklung aber ist was man
bislang ja nicht sagt weil
naturkonstanten sind naturkonstante ja
ok ja ich meine es gibt so okay wir sagt
mir dass man vielleicht auch noch mal
ein schwieriger und zwei seiten 2
aber ich meine diese sozusagen physik
historische einschätzung von bohlen ja
wir haben eigentlich immer sehr vom raum
her gedacht
die dass das stimmt wahrscheinlich also
auch jetzt noch mal an die anderen
seiten angesprochen worden sind
anzudocken
ich glaube das selbe gilt auch für die
für die philosophie und psychologie
natürlich auch als wir haben immer
versucht die zeit quasi über den
veränderungen im raum irgendwie oder
daumen metaphorik des hat jetzt aber
lang lang haben wir schon wieder den
raum genau also weil ich die zeit ebenso
nicht unmittelbar ausdrücken kann
benutze ich dann raum metaphorik weil
wir jetzt so viel über die psychologie
geredet haben und so wichtig die physik
derzeit auch sein mag die physiker haben
über eines nie so richtig ernsthaft und
gerne nachgedacht dass sie das was sie
für objektiv halten als subjekte also
als menschen beobachten müssen auch
wissenschaftler sind ja biologische
lebewesen übrigens auch soziale wesen
lebewesen doch genau diese biologische
dimension fand ist vor kurzem wenig
beachtung
dabei brauchen wir um zeit zu messen und
zu verstehen nicht nur instrumente und
augen und sinne sondern natürlich auch
ein gehirn sogar gefühle
und das hat seine eigene zeit struktur
und bestimmt das gehirn wie wir heute
wissen unsere zeit wahrnehmung in einem
sehr erheblichen maß nachlesen können
sie das übrigens in einem artikel der
aktuellen oktober-ausgabe von spektrum
der wissenschaft den artikel von marc
widmann über zeit und zeit wahrnehmung
können sie sich dort gratis runterladen
[Musik]
zeit mal rast sie dahin dann scheint
sieht raum zu vergehen
warum empfinden wir die zeit so
unterschiedlich gehirnforscher versuchen
seit langem das geheimnis der zeit
wahrnehmung zu lüften
die neuesten befunde belegen die
inselrinde ist stark an ihr beteiligt
dieses hirnareale steuert auch die
körper wahrnehmen
die sogenannte insula ist für die
aufnahme von körper gefühlen zuständig
unsere körper zustände sind gleichzeitig
die basis für komplexe gefühl unser
ganzes körper system unsere gefühle und
hormone sind daran beteiligt wie wir
zeit wahrnehmen
sie alle schaffen unser zeitgefühl für
zeitdauer
doch unser zeitgefühl drückt uns
gelegentlich die zeit scheint mal
schneller mal langsamer zu laufen
seit langem bekannt emotionale und
körperliche einflüsse können die zeit
einschätzung stark beeinflussen
in shrek momenten beispielsweise kommt
es zu einem zeitlupen effekt obwohl der
körper auf die über lebenssituation mit
höchster erregung reagiert und auch die
denkvorgänge schneller ablaufen laufen
die außen ereignisse langsamer auch
bilder mit positiven oder negativen
inhalt die in uns starke emotionen
hervorrufen bewirken eine streckung von
erlebter dauer fanden wissenschaftler
heraus
wie wir unser leben bestimmt die
subjektive zeitdauer eines ereignisses
jeder kennt diese situation die zeit
will nicht vergehen wenn wir lange
warten müssen
von nichts abgelenkt sind wir auf uns
selbst zurückgeworfen und spüren uns
ganz intensiv während des untätigen
herumsitzen es kommt uns die zeit sehr
lang vor umgekehrt ist es wenn wir
körperlich und geistig angeregt sind um
vieles an einem tag erleben wir sind so
damit beschäftigt die vielfältigen
eindrücke aufzunehmen und zu verarbeiten
dass wir keine zeit haben über die
abgelaufene zeit nachzudenken
unsere ich wahrnehmung ist reduziert
deshalb vergeht zeit für uns sehr
schnell
in der rückschau passiert das gegenteil
ein mit vielen tätigkeiten und
erlebnissen ausgefüllter tag führt zu
einer großen sammlung ab gespeicherter
inhalte und lässt die erlebte zeit
deshalb lang erscheinen
der alltag dagegen der aus routine des
immer gleichen besteht wird nicht mehr
aufwändig im gedächtnis gespeichert im
nachhinein wirken die alltäglichen
ereignisse wie nicht gelebt und
hinterlassen den eindruck die zeit sei
verflogen
wissenschaftler sprechen von einem zeit
paradoxon
doch wir sind derzeit nicht hilflos
ausgeliefert
wir können die subjektive zeit steuer
gegen das versinken im schnell und
eintönig fließenden zeit strom hilft
neue eindrücke in der innen oder außen
welt zusammen zum beispiel im urlaub die
in urlaubs momenten rasch verfliegen der
zeit dehnt sich in der rückschau dann zu
einem langen prall gefüllten zeit boden
wir können derzeit auch verlangsamt zb
durch meditation
wenn wir uns mit allen sinnen auf
unseren körper konzentrieren und von
nichts abgelenkt sind können wir mit der
so veränderten bewusstseins erfahrung
manchmal sogar zeitlosigkeit empfinden
die wir also zeit wahrnehmen und
empfinden es stark verknüpft mit unserem
bewusstsein
doch auch wenn wir mittlerweile viel
über die zeit wahrnehmung wissen in
vielerlei hinsicht bleibt trotzdem ein
rätsel
wenn wir jetzt sagen hat man
herausgefunden
dann ist das einen einen zeitraum da
sind wir wieder bei der raum metapher
der länger ist als eine viertelsekunde
und kleiner als drei sekunden danach
beginnt ein neues jetzt und wieder ein
neues jetzt weiß man inzwischen warum
das so ist warum überhaupt ein jetzt für
uns existiert ist als funktion ganz klar
wir müssen uns irgendwie einigen
koordinieren synchronisieren wenn ich
spreche müssen sie das was ich spreche
zeitlich auch verstehen entwickeln wir
hände schütteln wir müssen quasi
gemeinsam synchron eine zeitliche
plattform in unter in unserer
interaktion haben dass ich eine innere
vorgestellten tonbandgerät was was läuft
und da kommt sozusagen alles drauf aber
das ist ja ein tonbandgerät was
praktisch drei sekunden macht dann kommt
der bruch das nächste zeitfenster drei
sekunden das nächste zeitfenster so
würden viel zu da gibt es hinweise aber
die sind sowieso neurowissenschaftlich
aus eeg dass es tatsächlich so einheiten
gibt also schwingungen im gehirn gibt
die diese ungefähre dauer haben von
mehreren sekunden und die integrierten
ereignisse zusammen
auch auf diesen tatsächlich 23 45
sekunden zeit horizont aber phänomenal
ist natürlich was ganz besonders wir
haben natürlich ein klapp gehackte drei
sekunden und als sei er so wir bewegen
uns in einem dauernden jetzt wo die
zukunft auf uns zukommt aber das
erklären sie in ihrem buch eigentlich
für mich sehr nachvollziehbar das hängt
damit zusammen dass wir ein kurzzeit und
langzeitgedächtnis haben in diesem
jeweiligen zeitfenster rufen wir unser
kurzzeitgedächtnis sagen dass es
speichert wenigstens mein letztes
gespräch mit ihm
er kann also da fühle ich mich in
kontinuität mit mir selber und langzeit
macht das dann noch mal viel länger also
keine ahnung aber man kann sagen unser
präsenz gefühl dass wahrscheinlich doch
sehr gespeist zb das arbeitsgedächtnis
ständig kommen neue inhalte rein über
die zeit hinweg aber die verliere ich
natürlich auch wieder alles was jetzt
vor der 5 10 15 20 sekunden passiert ist
ist auch das meiste ist auch schon
wieder verloren und über verschiedene
modalitäten fliegt es so aus unserem
gedächtnis raus und deswegen haben wir
quasi und das gefühl in meinem jetzt zu
sein und nicht das wird nicht immer
breiter immer länger länger so nicht
sagen immer ein statisches denkt man
jetzt von mehreren sekunden dauern
warum spielt körperlichkeit und
emotionen bei derzeit wahrnehmung so
eine rolle wenn man es überlegen zeit
wäre rede von zeit wahrnehmung also
denkt dann denkt man vielleicht ein
sensorisches system aber wir haben ja
keinen sensorisches organ wie die augen
für sehen oder die [ __ ] fürs hören und
auch im gehirn gibt es kein areal wo er
sagt das ist das zeichen areal also kein
organ kein zeit areal also muss müssen
wir irgendwie eine andere weise haben um
den verlauf der zeit wahrzunehmen und
damit so oder erwartungen entsprechend
in die zukunft zu planen
und da ist dann eine möglichkeit und das
ist eine naheliegende möglichkeit dass
unser körperlichkeit unsere
körperlichkeit über die zeit die signale
die wir uns von unserem körper empfangen
über die zeit benutzen um zeitdauer zu
messen denn das ist ja immer da es wird
immer ständig so wie wir da sitzen
werden diese signale hoch geschickt und
das kann uns vielleicht dann unabhängig
von allen anderen sinnesorgane und zeit
definieren das merken wir dann eben
insbesondere zum beispiel in der
langeweile oder er weiß ich vorher
meinte wenn man jemanden eine stunde in
den raum sperrt man ist nicht abgelenkt
von sich dann spüren wir uns mit unserer
körperlichkeit ganz deutlich und wir
sind ganz präsent und dann spüren wir
zeit als ganz langsam verdient also
körperlichkeit als unsere in der ruhe
wir sind unsere eigene innere uhr wenn
man so will
ich finde man das ist da so einer er sie
wollte mal fragen gab
ich stimme ihm vollkommen zu dass wir
keine spezielle sinnes modalität für die
zeit haben aber weil wir eben schon
davon gesprochen haben man sollte zeit
nicht so sehr herr räumlichen finde ich
als sinnes modalität was zurzeit
betrifft besonders spannend das hören
also weil das natürlich wie man das
sehen ist offensichtlich sehr eng mit
dem räumlichen verknüpft und das hören
mit dem zeitlichen und dass wir da die
das spannende phänomen haben das fast
sämtliche sinnes qualitäten die wir da
haben an zeitliche regularien gekoppelt
sind als die tonhöhe ist eine zeitliche
regula riet der die klangfarbe selbst
das richtungshören dass das ihre stimme
jetzt von rechts kommt hat was mit der
unterschiedlichen laufzeit der schall
und das würde ich sagen das macht dass
das hören noch mal eine sehr spannende
sache und wird auch gern noch mal das
unterstreicht die gesagt haben
sie hatten ja gesagt es gibt auch andere
methoden wie eeg weil in dem film wurde
sehr viel auf emi also auf die
lokalisation hingewiesen dass es halt
auch wieder räumlich und ich würde sagen
ja wenn wir wissen wollen wie zeit
wahrnehmung funktioniert ist die antwort
wo nicht allein die spannende sondern ja
auch vor allen dingen das wie und das
wird die möglichkeit auch in den
neurowissenschaften haben zeitliche
verläufe zeitliche strukturen zu messen
und da würde ich sagen da wird es auch
philosophisch dann spannend weil dann
könnte auf der einen seite gucken
physiologisch was was baut sich das
bauen sich dafür antworten auf und ab
wie es da die wie es da die dynamik und
auf der anderen seite hat der psychologe
und der philosoph da seine schuldigkeit
zu tun wie wir glauben wir dass auf der
phänomenalen ebene sinnes qualitäten
überhaupt entstehen können
und dann können wir diese versuchen
diese strukturen zu vergleichen und das
scheint mir ein spannender punkt zu sein
und kann auch hoffentlich dazu führen
dass man das in fruchtbarer weise macht
und nicht nicht mehr auf gleich ob so
ein priorität streit kommt das ist doch
alles das gehirn
die poren in transzendentaler ganze
körper ist es doch genau das gehirn
alleine sowieso nicht dass uns führt
dabei bietet sein dass das führt nur
weiter wenn man sich radikal von dieser
vorstellung ist gebe einen abstrakten
raum und es gebe eine absage derzeit
trennt und wirklichen organismus ins
zentrum des ganzen geschehens rütteln ja
diese organismus körperwahrnehmung ist
derjenige der zeit daran erlebt dass er
sich als zerfallen war nimmt sich als
jemand der auch wenn er ganz still am
tisch sitzt und ein wasserglas wasser
vor sich hat schon wieder ein bisschen
älter geworden ist als eben noch ja das
erschütternde an der zeit ist ja dass
sie auftaucht jetzt ist und ich ihn
jetzt schon weiß dass dieses jetzt
gleich nicht mehr da sein wird
körperlich soziale im hören und ihm
sehen erleben wir dauernd den zerfall
der welt oder besser gesagt müssten wir
uns physikalisch und biologisch
beschreiben als jemand würde er da auch
einkommen serial der welt erlebt und
dieses kompensiert durch erinnerungen
durch erwartungen durch festhalten
zukunftsprojekte gucken ja und durch
durch alle möglichen maßnahmen die dann
doch time binding zeit bindung
herstellen und dann irgendwann dieses
merkwürdige gefühl ergeben dass die zeit
fließt sie fließt aber nicht zerfällt ja
das finde ich und das kann man nur sehen
wenn man den organismus mit seiner
wahrnehmungsfähigkeit ins zentrum rückt
und nicht mit kant von irgendwelchen
regulativen ideen aus geht wie uns
gleichsam aus dem kosmos heraus zu hilfe
eilen was ich aber total spannend fand
an dem was sie herausgefunden haben dass
das ist ja das ist ja relativ neu ist
ohne dass jetzt wieder verheimlichen zu
wollen
das ist ja einen teil des gehirns gibt
die so genannte insula die dafür
zuständig ist diese ganzen verschiedenen
eindrücke von denen sie gerade sprachen
zu einer zu einer einheit zu bringen zu
einem einheitlichen ja was auch immer
gefühl prozess bild den wir dann ich
oder selbst oder wie auch immer nennen
also wir haben wir dann hörzentrum
gehören ein sehzentrum im gehirn und so
haben wir wenn man so will auch ein
körper zentrum und in solar deren
aufgabe ist eigentlich die signale aus
dem körper zu empfangen und zu
verarbeiten und auch zu das ist dann
wahrscheinlich wieder diese integration
mit allem unserer mentalen mit an
unserem denken den sozialen situation
unserer wahrnehmung zu integrieren zu
einem ganzen und ist meine
körperlichkeit als anker der da ist und
diese in sola quasi erst einmal körper
repräsentation hier jetzt über die zeit
und damit aber auch schafft es dass
unsere gefühl von verlauf der zeit ist
aber eben auch der körperliche anker
eben eine körperlichkeit ist das worauf
alle anderen mentalen prozesse wenn man
soll aufgebaut sind auch zu laufen der
anker und damit zu sagen ist die insel
auch ganz wesentlich für sowas wie
selbstbewusstsein was passiert in drogen
oder auch meditations- erfahrung wenn
wir das gefühl haben da ist überhaupt
keine zeit mehr
das ist natürlich ganz seltene
erfahrungen die man aber auch induzieren
können wie sie sagen das ist natürlich
was ganz was spannendes an dem ich auch
jetzt forscher da ist es wahrscheinlich
was passiert ist dass ich über die
augenblicks erfahrungen die pure
augenblicks erfahrung und es kann in der
meditation sein es kann aber auch durch
halluzinogenen sein
das heißt dass ich vergangenheit und
zukunft ausschalte und nur noch
augenblicklich um einen 3 sekunden
fenster vielleicht in so einem art puren
drei sekunden fenster bin und dann
zukunft vergangenheit ist weg ich bin
nur noch jetzt im moment und dann ist
zeitlosigkeit gegeben verändert sich
dann was in der insel das wäre ganz
schön hypothese also es gibt zum
beispiel dass es die prothesen die ich
natürlich auch verfolge auch arbeiten
von backbreaker amerikanischen euro an
thom der hat zusammen mit kollegen in
der schweiz und schweden gezeigt zb bei
patienten mit epilepsie diese
ekstatischen erfahren
und da hat man nachgewiesen was dir
erfahren ist nämlich für wenige sekunden
bis minuten maximal minuten dass sie von
diesem gefühl für unglaubliche präsenz
ich jetzt hier auch glücksgefühle fast
drogen artige mystische glücksgefühle
erleben und auch die körperliche präsenz
ganz schön fast organisch und dann aber
es plötzlich über übergeht in einem
gefühl von zeitlosigkeit raum losigkeit
und die konnten auch mit eeg und anderen
verfahren nachweisen diese forscher dass
da insbesondere auch die an terrier in
salla waren mit betroffen ist in diesen
zuständen dieser ekstatischen augen wenn
die zeit eckfeld also viel eine über
erregung in diesem körper system wird
dann besonders aktiv die in solar- oder
verändert sich so anders damals die
besonders aktiv das ist das synchrone
feuern was die epileptischen anfall
außen macht also ein ungesundes zeug
synchron ist von oder ist zunächst
einmal die unglaubliche präsenz und
körpergefühls heftigkeit die drei ist
und dass wenn es noch weiter
übersteigert ist dann quasi geht es auch
in die bewusstlosigkeit
bei den überlegungen zum heutigen thema
zeit war uns bald klar dass wir neben
der physikalischen unter
neurowissenschaftlichen dimensionen auch
über einen aspekt der zeit sprechen
wollten und sollten der heute weitgehend
vernachlässigt wird nämlich den sozialen
damit ist aber weit mehr gemeint als nur
das dauer-thema beschleunigung und
entschleunigte gesellschaft usw
denn das ist nur die oberfläche von
soziokulturellen und ökonomischen
prozessen darunter liegt ein
fundamentales problem das ich sehr gut
in der sprache der systemtheorie
erfassen lässt
diese geht auf niklas luhmann unter
anderem zurück denn einem zunächst
entlegenen bereich strukturen von zeit
erforscht nämlich in einem artikel den
er im zusammenhang mit der analyse von
verwaltungen und politischer planung
schrieb diese artikel fördert zu fangen
wir überraschendes zutage
luhmann erklärt nämlich zeit anhand von
werten und präferenzen seiner
untersuchung zufolge ist zeit an sich
weder positiv noch negativ zeit ist
einfach nur ein medium und zwar das
medium schlechthin in dem entscheidungen
gefällt werden und in dem wir handeln
das lässt sich im folgenden film gut an
drei aktuellen ereignissen zeigen an der
ukraine krise die weil sie in europa
stattfindet im dauer fokus der medien
steht an der krise beziehungsweise dem
krieg im nord-irak über den immer wieder
mit pausen berichtet wird und dann am
thema ebola das lange schon bedrohlich
war aber nicht ernsthaft wahrgenommen wo
bis vor knapp zwei wochen dran und nun
heißt es sei gerade mit blick auf ebola
die zeit knapp zeit an sich ist nicht
knapp behauptet der soziologe niklas
luhmann warum seine begründung lautet
der eindruck der zeitknappheit entsteht
erst aus der überforderung des erlebens
durch erwartungen zeithorizont und
verwaltungsstruktur müssen daher in
einklang gebracht werden
zeit ist die differenz zwischen
erwartung und erfüllung für lohmann ist
das was dazwischen liegt sehr
vielschichtig wie bewältigen wir die
fülle der möglichkeiten wie reduzieren
wir die komplexität luhmanns antwort
durch entscheidungen
sie führen zu handlungen im system
zeitdruck kann durch arbeitsteilung und
kooperation entstehen
da zeigt nicht beliebig verfügbar ist
gibt es ständig termine und fristen mehr
halten erfordert zeit dies bedeutet für
lumen wer in einer sozial komplexen welt
leben will und deshalb viel konsens
braucht strapaziert damit sein
zeitbudget im krieg dominiert der befehl
mit dieser kommunikationsform wird
schnelligkeit erzielt und zeit gespart
von drei parallel ereignissen stand
zunächst der ukraine konflikte
mittelpunkt der politik wegen der nähe
zu europa und der gefahr einer
eskalation erhielt diese region die
aufmerksamkeit steigt die koordinations
bedürftigkeit prognostiziert nun an
lassen sich termine nicht mehr isolieren
sondern geraten in abhängigkeit
voneinander
sie müssen nicht nur zeitlich sondern
auch thematisch aufeinander abgestimmt
werden
termine erzeugen termine so pflanzt sich
der zeitdruck fort als die us-angriffe
gegen milizen flogen geriet der kampf
gegen den terrorismus wieder ins
blickfeld der politik der vormarsch der
fundamentalisten soll nach bekanntem
muster mit gewalt gestoppt werden
zitat luhmann aus der knappen
entscheidungs zeit ergibt sich eine
bevorzugung des schon bekannten der
eingefahrenen denkbaren eine bevorzugung
der kommunikationspartner mit denen man
sich rasch verständigen kann
alles in allem eine tendenz zur
entscheidung aus dem inneren des systems
heraus
im politischen system verändern sich
dringlichkeiten im laufe der zeit so
können ereignisse die vor monaten nur
wenig beachtet wurden mit wachsender
verbreitung und steigenden opferzahlen
an bedeutung gewinnen
präferenzen verschieben sich luhmann
erklärt der wert einzelner werte hängt
immer von dem erfüllung stand anderer
werte ab die anhänger anderer werte
werden nicht diskreditiert man mutet
ihnen nur wartezeiten zu eine ausnahme
bilden jene politischen entscheidungen
deren auswirkungen wie in fukushima ihre
version sind dürfen also
parlamentarische beschlüsse stattfinden
wenn es ein hohes katastrophenrisiko
gibt die vielfalt der handlungsoptionen
ist nach dem desaster stark
eingeschränkt die zeit fungiert dann nur
noch begrenzt als medium für
handlungsalternativen und veränderungen
die katastrophe ist zeitlos luhmanns
resümee die orientierung an fristen und
frisst bedingten vor dringlichkeiten
bestimmt den rhythmus der arbeit und die
wahl ihrer thematik daraus folgt es gibt
keine absolute wert ordnung aber
weitreichende einflüsse der zeit
es gibt keine absolute ordnung das gilt
ja auch für solche themen ich hab's der
eingangs gesagt wie die ukraine oder
oder ebola
das hängt zusammen mit werten
was bedeutet das für die zeit diesem
zusammenhang zwischen entscheidungen den
ich in einem bestimmten fenster treffen
muss und diesen werten
er würde vielleicht etwas umgekehrt
fragen welche rolle spielt die zeit
derart dass wir werte oder so etwas wie
fristen brauchen ja die frist ist hat
der beitrag ja gerade wunderbar
klargemacht die frist ist etwas die es
mir erlaubt mich in meinem verfahren in
dem moment eingespannt bin zu wehren
dagegen dass irgendwelche anderen
akteure kommen und sagen
konntest du für uns nicht das tun ja die
frist sagte niki hat vor durch morgan
dass ich vor dringlichkeit ich muss das
tun und vielleicht danach dass die werte
erfüllen eine dieselbe funktion für
allgemeiner teilweise ja dann kann man
sagen ich weiß zwar nicht genau ob der
zweck den ich gerade erreichen möchte
mit max weber der richtige ist aber der
wehr den ich vertrete aufrichtig zu sein
spontan zu sein klug zu sein es ist
genau das was mir meine handlungen in
dem moment zu begründen erlaubt wieder
in der verteidigung gegen andere
handlungs ansprüche weil es ja immer
darum geht dass wir diese diese vielfalt
von systemen habe klein und großen
system haben die alle in diesen in diese
zerfallende zeit hinein gebaut sind und
nun miteinander darum konkurrieren
ressourcen zu bekommen was ich hören
wichtigste ressource sind wir selber was
ich eine totale parallelität mit dem
neurowissenschaftlichen zeitfenster
finde weil da konkurrieren sozusagen
verschiedene teilsysteme unseres gehirns
miteinander immer wieder zerfallen und
müssen sich synchronisieren das ist
eigentlich etwas ganz ähnliches wie das
was sie gerade beschrieben haben
also wenn man sich das einzeln euro und
so vorstellen möchte wieder in die
wiederum vielleicht ja das würde ich
jetzt gar nicht diese zucker das zucker
da immer etwas gibt es in analogie
schlüssen
wir haben ja auch für falsch der jeder
im schnitt jeder einzelne
erkenntnisfortschritt sei es in der
psychologie sei in der physik und der
soziologie zeigt dass man irgendwie
immer wieder ganz anders denken muss
dann fange ich noch mal anders an was
ich meine ist dass es eine parallelität
doch gibt von diesem fenster über das
wir gesprochen haben
und da kommen jetzt alle möglichen
gesellschaftlichen eindrücke auf mich zu
ja der eine der willig soll das morgen
abgeben übermorgen ich muss aber
gleichzeitig noch was anderes tun als
eine ungeheure komplexität eben die muss
sich ordnen und diese komplexität muss
ich reduzieren um überhaupt darauf
reagieren zu können
also so wird ein schuh draus ja weil ich
dann wieder so stadt wieder sagen kann
das faktum der zeit schlechthin ist
diese universität die ich in der familie
erleben die ich bei der arbeit erlebe
die ich in der politik erleben und die
ich nun untereinander koordinieren muss
weil ich an mich irgendwie zwei jahre
meines lebens in der familie verbringen
kann und anschließend mich wieder auf
meinen job kümmern und dann irgendwann
auch zur wahl gehe sondern dies alles
parallel
läuft die parallelität also die
gleichzeitigkeit all diese vorgänge
verlangt dass ich mit unterschiedlichen
zeithorizonten sortiere was wann wichtig
ist die familie verlangt dass der
mülleimer heute morgen runter gebracht
wird die politik verlangt dass ich im
nächsten monat zur wahl geht zur wahl
gehe und ich kann mit minimalen zukunft
und vergangenheit horizonte genau diese
verhältnisse so sortieren dass mir die
zeit sagt warum die systeme
unterschiedlich aufgestellt sind
da man hier noch mal nachfragen haben
doch eben gesagt die zeit existiert
eigentlich für das system gar nicht
sondern was existiert sind die werte
nach denen wir diese verschiedenen
abläufe also soll ich jetzt in der
politik weiter machen oder mich doch
jetzt erst mal um die familie kümmern
indem ich die ordner und entsprechend
entscheidungen treffe und handle
ja das war meines erachtens nicht gesagt
sondern wir haben gesagt die welt
existieren weil weil das system ist mit
dem problem der zeit zu tun hat das
heißt die zeit ist wirklich nichts
anderes als die bedrohung des systems
mit der möglichkeit keine anschlüsse
ereignis zu finden stell dir vor es ist
universität und ab morgen geht keiner
mehr hin
stell dir vor es ist politik und ab
morgen interessiert sich keiner mehr
dafür was rein zeitlich weil der unter
der der moment von morgen ein anderer
moment ist der moment von heute durchaus
möglich wäre also muss ich jetzt schon
was dafür tun dass die universität
attraktiv bleibt dass die politik das
attraktiv bleibt dass ich mir selber
attraktiv bleibe und dieser aufwand den
baue ich wie sie eben so schön gesagt
haben in dieses medium zeit hinein mit
wie gesagt minimalen zukunftserwartung
vergangenheits erwartungen und einem
gleichzeitigkeit verständnis aber immer
in dem verdrängten bewusstsein erst mit
einem problem zu tun zu haben so immer
zu tun zu haben dass bereits morgen
unlösbar werden könnte nämlich dann wenn
ich sterbe
was ja zu der folgerung führt das zeit
nichts ist was für mich alleine
existiert sondern zeit existiert aus der
perspektive gesehen gesellschaftlich
gesehen nur weil ich ständig mit anderen
interagieren
die ansprüche an mich stellen
die bestimmte dinge von mir verlangen
und das muss ich irgendwie zusammen
kriegen
das haben wir ja im ersten beitrag schon
wunderbar gesehen dass das der der
rhythmus des jahres dass die biographien
mit ihren mit ihren aufwachsen kindern
älterwerden erwachsenen sterbenden
großeltern dass die zeit der arbeit das
in der tat in der tat die zeit der
politischen entscheidung jeweils mit
unterschiedlichen rhythmen konfrontiert
sind aus einer inneren logik heraus die
aber nicht jetzt nicht sozusagen aus der
zeit erklärt werden muss dann aus der
sache erklärt werden muss
die zeit kommt dass da hinspiel wo
während ich in der politik versuche eine
entscheidung zu finden schon merke dass
die wirtschaft entscheidung getroffen
hat die meiner entscheidung unmöglich
machen oder umgekehrt
das heißt der der entscheidende punkt
ist eigentlich der dass das worüber
werden nachdenken können und müssen er
die sachfragen und die art und weise der
sozialen aufstellung des umgangs mit
diesem sachfragen sind für alle
gemeinsam stellt sich wenn man so will
dasselbe zeitproblem dasselbe deswegen
weil jedes system mit seiner umwelt
andere systeme hat die mit anderen
rhythmen konfrontieren warum sagt
lohmann dann zeit es nicht knapp
weil sie kann ab gemacht wird ich mache
mir meine zeit knapp dann bitte ich mich
vor diesem hintergrund gegen andere
zugriffe wehren kann und weil ich dann
natürlich merke ich mehrere mit zwar mit
erfolg
aber plötzlich habe ich den zeitdruck
dem ich mal selbst schuldig du siehst ja
wir sind ja genial in der verdrängung
unserer eigenen verantwortung für unsere
eigenen folgen ja vielleicht kann man
das auch anknüpfen eine unterscheidung
dies eine philosophie auch im anschluss
an die phänomenologie gibt zwischen
weltzeit und eigenzeit also ich weiß
ganz genau passt weil dass wir einmal
diese soziale dimension von zeit haben
an dem wir uns orientieren müssen wir
uns auch sachen vorgibt wo jetzt das was
eben diskutiert wurde hinein
hineingehört das als weltweit bezeichnen
auf der anderen seite gibt es jeweils
die wirklich individuell subjektiv
empfundene und so schien jetzt ja auch
ein bisschen der plot unserer sendung zu
sein das wäre eben von dem individuellen
jetzt ein bisschen auf das
gesellschaftliche kommen ich glaube
jetzt kann man auch mal den bogen zurück
sparen und dann sagen was in dem film
auch vorher mit der langeweile dass
diese phänomene unter denen man dann
leidet das da die immer was damit zu tun
haben dass meine eigene zeit plötzlich
mit der welt zeit irgendwie nicht mehr
überein stimmt ich bin vor vorweg ja ich
bin mit essen fertig alle um mich herum
sitzen essen noch jetzt muss ich warten
oder das umgekehrte phänomen alle
anderen sind fährt dann haben diese der
zeitdruck ist dann wir uns bei allen
genau und das dann hin bis zu den
pathologischen fällen von von
depressionen wo ich das gefühl habe ich
komme immer schon mit immer zu spät ich
kann nichts mehr dran ändern aber so
eine gemeinsamkeit also zwischen allen
drei aspekten ist dass ich zeit nie für
sich bestimmen kann sondern zeit ist
relational das heißt zeit ist immer
bezogen auf ein system wie schnell
bewege ich mich wie integriere ich im
gehirn welche ansprüche stellen andere
an an mich also es in relationaler
begriffen nichts was ich sozusagen in
sich wie man das ja lange in der
philosophie versucht hat in sicht
definieren könnte warum läuft mir die
zeit davon das ist eben auch weil ich
termin orientiert zukunftsorientiert was
sie im system mich orientieren den
anderen und dann meine eigene zeit
verlieren weil ich nicht mehr auf mich
selber quasi mit meiner eigenen zeit
zurückgeworfen bin und weil ich
zukunftsorientiert bin merke ich mich
selbst nicht und dann vergeht die zeit
für schneller und es muss das verhältnis
zwischen zwei zeiten sein weil sonst
ganze also sozusagen zeit die zeit läuft
schnell das macht ja gar keinen das
macht ja gar keinen sinn weil das etwas
schneller oder langsamer es ist ja immer
in relation zu zurzeit und das heißt
wenn ich jetzt sage die zeit vergeht
schnell ist er kleider müssen irgendwie
zwei zeiten im spiel seien ein jahr oder
iran mindestens ein schuldiger das hat
einen mathematischen sinne die weltzeit
würde die würde ich nicht glauben
sondern ein dutzende von aigen zeiten
und dabei finde ich wiederum interessant
dass wir es ja auch sehr genießen dass
uns die zeit davon
es gibt eine ganz berühmte beratungs
technik im fall von organisationen die
präsenz in gegenwart schaffen heißt wo
managern in einem kreis also eines
workshops angeboten wird doch mal für
einen moment an nichts außer sich selbst
zu denken
und zwar nur um die erleben zu lassen
dass sie genau das nicht aushalten
nächste frage ist ja und wohin soll das
führen ja wozu soll das gut sein
die halten ist nicht raus eine gegenwart
als gegenwart auf sich beruhen aber
nicht nur
gegenwart sondern sie halten sich selbst
nicht also das ist ja das ist es eben
dass es interessant ist dass er ja dass
er das mit dieser tollen perspektive
dass es menschen gibt die sich selbst
nicht aushalten würde ich die sendung
beschließen herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
sie meine damen und herren finden
weitere informationen darunter
interviews die bücher meiner gäste auch
buchbesprechungen wie immer auf unserer
internetseite www 3sat.de / scobel
ich selber habe bei der beschäftigung
mit dem thema zeit vor allem zwei dinge
gelernt erstens hängt zeigt sehr eng mit
unseren gefühlen unserem
körperbewusstsein zusammen deshalb ist
es möglich uns dem gefühlten zeitdruck
zu entziehen etwa durch achtsamkeit
training oder meditation in der durch
körpertraining zustände erreicht werden
in der zeit eben nicht mehr existiert
ich kann mich dann übrigens auch
aushalten als teammanager
zweitens existiert auch in der welt der
physik zeit nur als beziehung das hat
man ja zum schluss noch mal anders
ausgedrückt gerade das phänomen zeit
beweist dass es in wahrheit kein
einziges isoliertes system gibt auch
wenn wir immer so tun als gäbe es das
alle dinge existieren physikalisch
gesehen immer nur bezogen auf einander
sie entstehen und vergehen immer nur
alle zusammen die westliche philosophie
hat dafür keinen guten begriff finde ich
wohl aber die hinduistisch buddhistische
tradition die von der so genannten
abhängigen entstehung aller dinge
spricht das müsste noch weiter
ausgelotet werden können heute abend
nicht mehr machen deshalb schönen abend
noch
[Musik]